el objetivo de este vídeo es
esencialmente demostrar un resultado muy
bonito y muy simple y que es que la
proporción entre los volúmenes déjenme
déjenme escribirlo la proporción entre
los volúmenes del estado b y el estado a
lo que es es decir esta proporción entre
estos dos estados es igual y esto todo
esto lo vamos a hacer en un ciclo de
carne es igual a la proporción entre los
estados entre los estados del estado ce
y del estado de ok esta expresión que
escribí aquí es la que vamos a demostrar
es un resultado bastante sencillo y si
ya lo viste y para ti es suficiente ya y
ya estás contento con ello puedes dejar
de ver el resto del vídeo pero si eres
curioso de cómo llegamos a esto bueno
nos vamos a meter un poco con las
matemáticas va a ser una parte muy
divertida y además pues va a satisfacer
tu curiosidad de saber si esto es cierto
o no entonces vamos a empezar toda esta
demostración que sé que sé
que todo se resume a entender cuál es el
proceso a diabético es decir cuando
vamos de b a c y d
y desde aaa entonces si no tenemos una
transferencia de calor entonces q es
igual a cero estamos justo en esa parte
del ciclo donde es un proceso a
diabético verdad justo en esta en estos
dos
en estas dos trayectorias ahora estamos
en este proceso a diabético es decir
aislado del resto del universo verdad
por nuestra definición de él o más bien
por la primera ley de la termodinámica
sabemos que el cambio en la energía
interna es decir del tau es igual al
calor aplicado a el calor aplicado -
menos el trabajo realizado por el
sistema
- pero el trabajo realizado es la
presión por el cambio en el volumen no
es decir
si se puede escribir de esta forma
verdad puedes verlo la presión lo puedes
ver como una constante para pequeños
cambios del volumen así que si esto es a
diabético sabemos que q es igual a cero
justo y si eso es 0 entonces podemos
sumar p del tav de ambos lados de la
ecuación y lo que obtendremos es lo
siguiente si estamos en un proceso a
diabético que del tau más
del tav es decir nuestro cambio en el
volumen es igual a 0 y veamos cómo
podemos trabajar con esto con esta
ecuación para obtener el resultado que
tenemos en la mira entonces hace unos
vídeos demostramos que a la energía
interna del sistema en cualquier momento
déjenme escribirlo es desigual ah no
perdón es tres medios n r t ok entonces
esto es la energía interna y ahora si
tenemos un cambio en la energía interna
como cambia del lado derecho algo debió
haber cambiado bueno tres medios no
cambia n tampoco ya que tenemos el mismo
número de moléculas r es una constante
así que lo único que puede cambiar es la
temperatura y ahí lo tienen del tau lo
podemos reescribir del tau déjenme
ponerlo en otro color del tau lo podemos
escribir como tres medios
r y el cambio en la temperatura y eso es
y esto es por lo cual sigo diciendo que
cuando estamos en esta situación la
energía interna es esencialmente la
energía cinética del sistema es decir si
no hay un cambio en la energía interna
no hay un cambio en la temperatura no
hay un cambio en la energía cinética así
que vamos a vamos a enmarcar esto esto
no se está midiendo el cambio en la
energía interna que esencialmente es el
cambio en la temperatura y vamos a ver
qué podemos hacer con nuestras
ecuaciones de gas es ideal es verdad
todo este sistema lo suponemos así y
sabemos que la presión por el volumen es
igual a la nrc verdad esta ecuación ya
la tienes que tener tatuada en la médula
para poder seguir trabajando con esto
así que si despejamos tenemos que es
igual a n rt sobre b
muy bien así que vamos a poner estas dos
en en un marco y vamos a sustituirlos en
la fórmula porque delta u es igual a la
primera actuación que tenemos que es
tres medios
nr del tate
más pe que en este caso es en rd sobre b
n r t sobre b y que multiplica a delta b
al cambio en el volumen ahora bien esto
es igual a cero
muy interesante esto que podemos seguir
haciendo aquí bueno nos va a decir qué
es lo que vamos a continuar haciendo
esto me está diciendo que me cambio en
la energía interna está relacionada con
del tate y que el trabajo está
relacionado con el cambio en el volumen
así que vamos a decir digamos si tenemos
pequeños incrementos vamos a llegar a
cero para pequeños incrementos así que
vamos a ver qué es lo que está pasando
con delta ve justo aquí dejen hacerlo en
un color más chillante este es el
pequeño cambio en el volumen verdad
estamos teniendo un pequeño cambio en el
volumen y no vemos aquí cuál temperatura
andamos pero bueno vamos a pensarlo
también en términos de área ok
la temperatura cambia un poco verdad es
en realidad cambia porque estamos
cambiando nos de isoterma
y vamos a tener que integrar
eventualmente a lo largo de todos los
pequeños cambios que hay en la
temperatura y en el volumen así que
déjenme ver cómo aplicar esto con el
cálculo así que vamos a dividir primero
todo por mrt entonces dividimos este
lado por rn t esté sumando también y por
supuesto del lado derecho de la ecuación
tenemos que hacer lo mismo
ok en este término se cancelan las n las
erres y nos queda eso y aquí todo este
en rt se va con éste nrc y con que nos
quedamos nos quedamos con tres medios
aquí tenemos 1 / t por delta t
+ + 1 / b por delta b que es igual a 0
verdad simplemente 0 / cualquier cosa es
0 ahora vamos a integrar todo a lo largo
de todos los pequeños cambios
dt y debe a así que déjenme cambiar a la
terminología de cálculo vamos a hacer
hacer sumas infinitesimalmente pequeñas
baja en del tate y delta b entonces
vamos a tener tres medios de uno sobre t
por de t más uno sobre b por db y esto
es igual a cero entonces recuerden que
esto significan cambios muy muy pequeños
en el volumen estos son cambios muy muy
pequeños en la infinitesimal mente
pequeños en la temperatura verdad y lo
que ahora quiero hacer es ver cuál es el
cambio total en la temperatura ok y el
cambio total en el volumen entonces
vamos a hacer eso así que esto lo
integramos desde nuestra temperatura
inicial hasta nuestra temperatura fina
ajá
y vamos a integrar este término desde el
volumen inicial al volumen final aquí
hay herramientas de cálculo que nos
ayudan a justificar este proceso que
realmente es por ejemplo el cuando
hacemos un cambio de variable verdad con
eso podríamos integrar de esta forma
pero bueno ahora chequeamos cuál es la
anti derivada de 1 entre t pues ya
sabemos que es el logaritmo natural de t
y esto lo tenemos que evaluar desde la
temperatura final hasta la inicial ok
más vamos a encontrar cuál es la anti
derivada de 1 entre b pues otra vez es
el logaritmo natural el logaritmo
natural de b y esto lo evaluamos bueno
tenemos el volumen final menos al
volumen inicial y ahora
esto va a ser igual a cero
digo si integramos de ambos lados al
integrar del lado derecho pues en
realidad la integral de 0 es 0 verdad
muy bien
entonces esto es igual a cero
vamos a ver que podemos seguir haciendo
entonces este estrés bueno vamos a
ponerlo así tres medios y el logaritmo
natural de una resta que es de la
temperatura final - la temperatura
inicial en realidad lo puedo poner como
el logaritmo natural del cociente es
decir de la temperatura final entre la
temperatura inicial
ok cuando evaluamos arriba tenemos
logaritmo natural de la temperatura
final y luego cuando evaluamos abajo es
menos el logaritmo natural de la
temperatura inicial ahora bien tenemos
logaritmo natural del volumen final
entre el volumen inicial de la misma
forma que hicimos con la temperatura ok
que es el logaritmo del volumen final
menos logaritmo de volumen inicial
entonces eso se traduce en un cociente
ahora este tres medios que tenemos aquí
este tres medios lo puedo meter a
logaritmo natural no multiplicando sino
como un exponente
entonces todo esto lo elevó a la tres
medios y si usamos aún las propiedades
del logaritmo tenemos suma de logaritmos
eso es igual al logaritmo de un producto
así que esto va a ser igual déjenme
cambiar de color esto va a ser igual al
logaritmo natural de t efe entre ts por
perdón a la 3 medios y esto
multiplicando a df entre bs ok
ya son bastantes cuentas verdad es el
logaritmo natural de todo esto y es
igual a cero
ahora que podemos decir bueno si tenemos
este logaritmo natural que nos da 0 qué
número nos da que es un logaritmo
naturales 0 bueno todo lo de adentro
tiene que ser igual a 1 verdad es decir
es decir vamos a tener que escribirlo de
esta forma que te f
ajá / t s que es la temperatura inicial
a la 3 medios que multiplica al volumen
final sobre el volumen inicial esto es
igual a 1
para que el logaritmo natural nos dé 0
verdad muy bien ya ya ya trabajamos
bastante para poder tener este resultado
que ya en sí es bastante interesante
pero ahora vamos a usar todavía que
estamos en este proceso a diabético y
bueno todo esto que hicimos en resumen
fue tomar las fórmulas de la energía
interna y de los gases ideales lo
aplicamos al cambio de la energía y
entonces obtuvimos al integrar a lo
largo de todos los pequeños cambios de
la temperatura y el volumen obtuvimos
este resultado que ya es bastante bueno
ok y eso es porque el logaritmo natural
de un número que no si nos da 0 quiere
decir que es el número tenía que ser 1
verdad el logaritmo natural de 1 es
igual a 0
así que fijémonos en el volumen b
está en temperatura 1 y el volumen se
que está en temperatura de 2 verdad
fíjense en el vídeo del ciclo de carne
por si ya no se acuerdan muy bien de
esto pero bueno están en isotermas
distintas
entonces aquí estamos en temperatura 1 y
aquí en temperatura 2 aquí volumen sé
muy bien así que en esta parte del justo
del proceso al final en está en nuestra
fórmula final nuestra temperatura final
teníamos que es temperatura 2 /
temperatura 1 y esto elevado a la 3
medios ahora cuál era nuestro volumen
final bueno era del estado cde verdad es
decir volumen c / volumen b que era
donde iniciamos nuestro proceso a
diabético y esto debe ser igual a 1
ahora vamos de vuelta al proceso a
diabético pero ya no vamos a pensar lo
debe hacer del estado de hace ya que nos
dan nuestros volúmenes iniciales y
finales ahora vámonos debe a que también
es un proceso a diabético es decir
podemos aplicar lo mismo y aquí la
temperatura final pues es cuando estamos
en el estado a que justamente es la
temperatura 1 ok
aquí en la estamos a la temperatura 1
que es nuestra nuestra temperatura final
entonces la temperatura final es de 1 y
la temperatura inicial es en el estado
de que era la temperatura 2 esto lo
elevamos a la 3 medios y ahora
multiplicamos por el volumen final que
en este caso es el volumen si se dan
cuenta que está volumen final entonces
es volumen en a sobre el volumen inicial
que es en el estado de y esto es igual a
1 muy bien ya casi estamos ahí a lo
mejor tus ojos ya están empezando a
ponerse en blanco de la emoción porque
esto ya se parece mucho y si seguimos
haciendo un poquito de matemáticas vamos
a ver ya casi podemos relacionar ambas
ambas este ambos resultados son lo que
vamos a tener que tomar el recíproco de
ambos lados de la primera ecuación
así que obviamente si tomamos el
recíproco de esta cosa esto es de 2 / t
1 al menos 3 medios o podríamos
simplemente pensarlo como que tomó de
uno sobre t 2 de 1 sobre t 2 a la 3
medios
ok este es el recíproco de la parte
naranja y que multiplica al recíproco de
la otra parte que es bebé sobre bc y
esto es el recíproco de uno que es uno
verdad sigue siendo el mismo
ok y eso iguala a esta segunda actuación
verdad porque ambos son iguales que uno
es decir que t 1 / t 2 a la 3 medios por
eb ea / v
y ahora estas dos naranjas son iguales
bueno antes que nada estas dos
expresiones son iguales déjenme ponerlo
bien porque hay parece que son
desiguales ambos igualan a uno entonces
son iguales entre sí así que podemos
poner que estas dos expresiones son
iguales y tenemos que la parte naranja
es la misma así que podemos cancelar la
verdad podemos cancelar esta parte
naranja si se desaparecen y con que nos
quedamos ya casi ves la línea final de
este ejercicio verdad porque tenemos que
bb sobre vece es igual a vea vea sobre
bebé
ahora no es exactamente el resultado que
queríamos pero con un poquito de
aritmética llegaremos ahí simplemente
vamos a multiplicar cruz de forma
cruzada y tenemos bebé por bebé es igual
a vea por pc por bc por vea es lo mismo
ok si dividimos ambos lados por déjenme
ver cuál cual nos funciona déjenme
dividir
déjenme dividir todo del lado izquierdo
y del lado derecho vamos a dividir sobre
b de b a bb b
tenemos esta división muy bien entonces
que obtenemos del lado derecho se
cancelan las veas y del lado izquierdo
las veces así que obtenemos bb sobre vea
es igual
abc sobre b de todo eso funciona
bastante bien es un resultado muy bonito
muy muy muy ilustrativo y digo aunque a
lo mejor las las operaciones y los
cálculos son un poquito engorrosos y
medio peludos en realidad todo esto lo
obtenemos al tratar un proceso a
diabético en donde nuestro cambio en el
calor es cero y obtuvimos nuestra
fórmula para relacionando el cambio del
volumen con la energía interna que en
esencia es el cambio en la temperatura y
que esto debe ser igual a cero verdad
entonces el trabajo realizado si te das
cuenta es un trabajo negativo pero
cuando opten obtuvimos el resultado de
la energía interna en un vídeo anterior
que es tres medios nrc
entonces podemos podemos relacionar el
cambio de la energía interna con el
cambio de la temperatura integramos a lo
largo de todos los pequeños cambios en
temperatura y volumen para movernos a lo
largo de esta línea ajá tomamos todos
los cambios y eso lo igualamos a cero
terminamos con esta fórmula de aquí
aplican aplicado a dos procesos a
diabéticos distintos cuando vamos de cee
perdón de véase idea y obtuvimos esta
última línea nos vemos en el próximo
vídeo